تعمل اجتماع الاسبوعي للحكومه تجنب رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
الحديثه عن اقاله وزير الداخليه
درعي واكتفى
بالحديث عن مباحثاته مع مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جيكس سوليفان الاسبوع
الماضي
زيارته جاءت في وقت خاص فهناك تحديات جديه
تواجهه امننا القومي
مع جيراننا تصدرت محادثاتنا تحديات
الامنيه والاقليميه وعلى راسها ايران
وايضا العمل وصول التعاون بيننا لهم
مواجهتها هذا التحدي المشترك علي ان اقول
انه في ختام لقاءاتنا كان لديه انطباعون
بان هناك رغبه متبادله وحقيقيه للتواصل
الى تفاهمات بشان هذه القضيه التي لها
اهميه حاسمه بالنسبه لامن دولتنا هذه
المباحثات ستستمر خلال الاسابيع المقبله
بيننا وبيننا واشنطن